Thinking back to our example,
the pizza cut into eight slices,
we remember that Bob and
I are sharing the pizza.
We know that if I eat two slices,
so these are my two slices,
that's me, and Bob, and this is Bob,
eats one slice of pizza,
that means we've eaten one,
two, three slices of pizza.
We remember from our
previous example that I
ate two-eighths of the pizza because two
slices out of the eight total slices.
And Bob ate one-eighth of the pizza,
that's his one slice out
of eight total slices,
and together we ate
three-eighths of pizza.
How can we find out how many
pieces of pizza are left?
Well, we could just count them and
see that we have one, two, three, four,
five pieces of pizza left but
I'd like to show this in a fraction.
To show what's going on with
the fraction, we should start with
eight-eights because that represents the
whole pizza, eight slices out of eight.
Then we should subtract the amount
that we've eaten already which is
three-eights.
This problem is in a convenient form for
us because we can see that
the denominators are the same.
They are common denominators.
When we have fractions like
this with common denominators,
all we have to do is
look at the numerators.
We know that no matter what
the fraction that results will
have an eight in the denominator.
So what's 8 minus 3?
5.
And when fractions have
common denominators,
we know that the denominator here will
be the same thing as what we have here.
So it's 8, five-eighths.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Just like when we counted.
So remember, when you have common
denominators in your fractions,
all you have to do is keep
the denominator the same.
And then add or
subtract what's in the numerator.